salut je suis actuellement en
centrafrique à bangui la centrafrique
c'est un pays d'afrique équatoriale qui
est très mal connue et qui est dans une
situation humanitaire à cette
désastreuse
s'était planté un couteau dans
mado
[Musique]
fin 2012 une coalition de groupes
rebelles principalement musulmans
appelés celica prend le contrôle d'une
grande partie de la république
centrafricaine en mars 2013
une pénètre dans la capitale bangui et
renverser le gouvernement
ce coup d'état est accompagnée de
violence extrême dans tout le pays les
rebelles de la cdca pillent violent et
massacrent les populations civiles
ces exactions entraîne la formation de
milices d'autodéfense principalement
chrétienne les antilles ballack à qui
elle même commettent de nombreuses
atrocités pendant plusieurs mois le pays
sombre dans le chaos et les violences
intercommunautaires
les nations unies par le même de
situation pré génocidaire
c'est le début d'une longue crise
sécuritaire et humanitaire qui dure
depuis près de six ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'échographie nous pouvons
célia on a mélangé a dominé grâce à ça
tu peux savoir que donnait d'entrée à
ses propres citoyens ne savent pas où
risque pour la vie et à une ambiance
hyper impressionnant de voir surgir sur
la personne et où j'ai l'impression que
les journées ici ce n'est sa en
permanence tout en tentant une cour
j'aime sf
[Musique]
l'affaiblissement des états c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui ça ne vient pas seulement
avec le cv cas on accourt me lécher sous
d'autres rebelles avant on a ce pays
je sais pas on parle de 14 groupes armés
aujourd'hui en a partout et aujourd'hui
on se retrouve dans une situation
extrêmement délicate
pas d'armé pas de 2,2 forte défense
sécurité pas de détails réellement type
fonctionnent
[Musique]
on va rentrer dans le bloc opératoire où
une dame qui s'est fait tiré dans la
jambe
[Musique]
bien sûr qui est assez courante ici
parce qu'on est dans un pays où il ya
beaucoup d'armes d'assaut beaucoup de 47
comme ça les choses vraiment l'habitude
de faire ça et en plus cela il s'agit
d'une personne qui vient d'un endroit
qui est assez loin de la capitale
elle a dû être transférée par avion pour
venir ici dans le seul endroit où les
gens pouvaient opérer et là ce qu'ils
vont faire c'est essayer de sauver la
jambe essayer de faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse remarcher assez de gens le jour
et si ça marche pas ils vont être
l'objet d'enquêtés
[Musique]
la malade a perdu beaucoup de sang plus
important de faire c'est le débridement
le plus tôt possible à dire 2
les v tous les 10 ou qui sont pas vivant
ce assez de muscle dos peau et même deux
morceaux de balles de trois choses on va
quitter nos questions après l'infection
pour réduire le risque d'amputation
[Musique]
donc là le personnel se terminer et
malheureusement les deux chirurgiens pas
aussi à sauver la jambe
en fait il se trouve que la balle était
passé à travers une artère et donc à des
sections une artère le pied n'est plus
irrigué dont vous sélectionné pour
éviter que les nécros tout une gangrène
pour une balle qui est passé dans sa
jambe elle se retrouve avec une jambe et
l'a8 au niveau de la cuisse quoi une
balle si ça tu passes un handicap
[Musique]
pour comprendre pourquoi la centrafrique
est aujourd'hui une zone de conflit il
faut remonter jusqu'en 1903 lors de la
création du pays par les français très
vite les colons sont rentrés dans une
logique d'exploitation des ressources
humaines et naturelles très agressive
les centrafricains ne va cultiver le
coton le café le caoutchouc est
également aménager le territoire
colonial notamment lors de la
construction de la ligne de chemin de
fer congo océan qui reliait le congo à
l'océan atlantique les exploiter les
gens presque pas de salaire ont coupé
les mains aux personnes qui ne
produisait pas assez les deux guerres
mondiales on en a souffert aussi
énormément
il avait la famine ici à cause de guerre
parce que tout ce qui était produit ici
été ramassés pour envoyer au front
donc on a passé des moments extrêmement
difficiles entre la fin du 19e siècle et
environ la moitié de la population
centrafricaine disparaît du à la
violence coloniale et aux maladies qui
en découlent le pays obtient finalement
son indépendance en 1960 mais depuis la
république centrafricaine vit au rythme
des guerres civiles et des coups d'état
[Musique]
lambeaux et cindy y voit église l'église
conseil commence ici prier même si assez
les cas à pic en baisse à l'appui jean à
c'est une nana d'amour guerre et me
bitty ou perde connaissance
face à young y avait un hôpital msf mata
zoo mais penser que la centrafrique est
honnête il souffrit mines qui dans iec
ici
c'est un handicap qu'il puisse trouver
son point quotidien dans leur famille
ils sont des personnes en trop et une
charge de plus s'il n'y avait pas d'aidé
humanitaire à bangui je pense qu'il y
aurait une catastrophe
bingo comment ceux-ci dirait swati
nations d'afrique qui at il ajouté
caroline galtier un appel si birsa sinaï
si jamais il y en a près une année
occupée jusqu'à la tension qu il bâtit
couilles mais il est inapte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les unit sécurité it anglais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a un castor qui est la maternité qui
se pose est de la plupart des naissances
de brouille est à la hausse - faire
c'est d'aller voir comment est ce qu'ils
font ça saute à vous constatez qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de mortalité infantile
grâce à vous ici par ailleurs nous avons
contribué effectivement a réduit
considérablement la mortalité et la
morbidité maternelle et néonatale satin
vert voilà une prise en charge de
qualité des gratuités
donc c'est accumula commandes les sens
pour moi ici ses environs autour de 800
voix vicent en essence par mois c'est en
1940 plus exactement ces fous ces
français là c'est la technique de la
masse automatique
voilà
cent vingt bébés et l'informent maman
notre présence ici est vraiment très
important parce que nous avons subi
beaucoup de filles nous avons apporté
beaucoup de sukkur à des mamans et tout
le monde a couru vers nous de 24
personnes
[Musique]
le truc que je trouve très
impressionnant c'est que c'est non
seulement gratuit en plus ils font
vraiment un gros suivi prennent en
charge les néonataux donc les bébés
prématurés
ils font de la prévention et font de
l'éducation sur comment j'avais un bébé
comment nourrir etc
c'est vraiment ils font un package
global de la pizza il s'unit mettons
manara qu'ils soient payés oui voilà
c'est mon idole il découvrit compagnie
cunard ans
où sont ils tombés money to balboni
si à ma chapelle et permis la digue à la
monotonie mon gars dynamique et légumes
et les herbes à oiseaux mais n'abuse
young money il se trouve que cette
maternité est juste en bordure du
quartier le plus chaud de bangui qu'on
appelle le pk 5
c'est le quartier d'où partirent la
barre des émeutes dont on entend parler
c'est un quartier où il ya des blindés
de l'onu qui circulent et nous en fait
on est juste à la lisière donc en fait
c'est des gens qui doivent gérer le
quotidien de la naissance dans un
contexte de crise
[Musique]
tous les événements qui se déroulent à
l'intérieur de pic à 5 notamment des
frictions entre les boues d'autodéfense
a une répercussion de direction nous les
femmes n'arrivent pas à accéder sur mon
cas stop ou accoucher dans de bonnes
conditions c'est quand même dangereux de
travailler ici c'est effectivement c'est
un peu dangereux parce que quand même
nous sommes dans une zone encore très
sensible de la capitale centrafricaine
et ça crée un peu une certains petits
posent au sein
voilà du staff d'abord et
particulièrement de nos passions puisque
nous sommes habitués ne savons comment
maîtriser le stress et nous sommes des
humanités notre rôle c'est de sauver les
gens qui sont en souffrance
ouais pourquoi nous sommes là donc même
si sa chose nous avons des techniques de
sécurité et en conduite toujours notre
rôle
[Musique]
je pense que les humanitaires m'en
propose un bon moment leur place ici en
centrafrique
aujourd'hui ça c'est clair on n'a pas
les moyens dans ce pays
militaires et humains de régler par la
force la question de l'art b2 alors est
ce que la république centrafricaine est
condamné à rester dans le chaos et la
violence
si la situation doit s'améliorer cela
passe nécessairement par un accord de
paix entre le gouvernement et les
ministres eux mêmes
et justement un accord a été signé en
février 2019
une avancée qui pourrait peut-être
marqué le début de la fin d'un conflit
qui dure depuis de 2013